[Musique]
dans huit secondes top
bonjour à tous ce matin tu dois vous
annoncer nouvelle à la fois triste et
troublante bien que j'ignore encore le
détail des faits qui lui sont reprochés
les couteaux ne me condamne de lens mon
collègue mais kesler avec qui j'ai
présenté cette émission pendant 15 ans
a été renvoyé aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on ne savait pas qu'on allait affronter
la plus grosse crise de notre histoire
on vient de [ __ ] ma vie en l'air sans
aucune raison
et s'apprête à vivre une renaissance
exceptionnel alex lévy est périmé depuis
des années je veux tu commences à former
de nouvelles personnes et n'importe
votre émission est à chier merci merci
pour l'info je veux des essais costumes
des essais caméra des essais maquillage
une fois un contre un où l avocat
les gens ont envie d'être sûr que celui
ou celle qui leur parlent de la réalité
du monde le fait avec schiste
[Musique]
comme vous oui
vos mots touché le cas de l'amérique les
genres de mort ont observé la dépression
nerveuse d'une femme pour qu'ils ont de
l'affection
un divertissement intemporel pour le
peuple américain
surtout être en mesure de contrôler la
situation pour ne pas être mise à
l'écart volé ma vie tu m'as laissé dans
les bois avec une meuf c'était de faire
ça fauteuils pourrait être le tient je
ne veux pas de votre emploi n'importe
quoi
[Musique]
tiens
tu pas cette porte tu pourras plus
jamais revenir la chose dont vous n'avez
pas l'air en avoir conscience
c'est que vous n'avez plus pouvoir je
vous ai laissé gérer la situation trop
longtemps bande de débiles
nous allons faire les choses à ma façon
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui est arrivé à ta télé on
n'était pas d'accord
[Musique]